mesdames messieurs bon dimanche
déception c'est le mot qui est revenu
dans le discours de chaque ministre des
provinces et des territoires à la sortie
de leur première rencontre en personne
pour discuter d'une nouvelle formule de
financement de la santé si la homologue
fédéral Jean-Yves Duclos se dit prête à
revoir la formule pour qu'elle soit plus
généreuse c'est bien gardé d'évoquer un
montant et a surtout formuler un certain
nombre de demandes dont l'accès aux
données des provinces en matière de
temps d'attente par exemple pour ont-ils
trouver un compromis sur le financement
et le partage d'informations tout en
protégeant les champs de compétences
j'en ai discuté avec le ministre
québécois de la santé Christian Dubé
mais d'abord la réaction de son
vis-à-vis fédéral à cette première ronde
de discussion tout ce que les premiers
ministres provinciaux ne cessent de dire
c'est qu'ils veulent une augmentation
inconditionnelle du Transfert canadien
en matière de santé et que ce soit
envoyé à leur ministre des Finances
ce n'est pas un plan c'est l'ancienne
façon de faire les choses si quelqu'un
en doutait encore la crise actuelle et
la preuve indéniable que l'ancienne
façon de faire ne fonctionne pas
question Dubé bonjour merci d'être avec
nous fait plaisir monsieur
Duclos que réclamait monsieur Duclos
cette semaine le ministre fédéral de la
santé c'est ça
c'est une partie ça c'est en fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle les fessaillants d'un
tableau qui est disponible dans le
public à tout le monde les gens peuvent
aller sur le site de québec.ca mais
peuvent aussi aller dans certains
onglets pas avoir un peu plus de détails
sur les urgences la première ligne la
santé mentale le niveau de soin à
domicile on a combien de personnes qui
sont en attente d'un soir à un domicile
etc donc il y a quand même pas mal
d'informations qui est disponible au
public si les données existent si elles
sont publiques si elles sont
transférables pourquoi c'est un problème
cette semaine comme Monsieur Duclos les
a demandé
il y a deux enjeux là
je suis pas un expert en constitution
mais il faut quand même dire les choses
comme elles sont l'éléphant dans la
pièce c'est un peu que la compétence
en santé c'est compétences provinciales
tu as toujours été ça a toujours été ça
a toujours été et moi je veux trouver
l'équilibre puis je pense que Monsieur
Duclos a le même objectif puis là-dessus
on se rejoint même si on ne sait pas
entendu cette semaine je pense qu'on va
continuer à se parler parce que si il
veut respecter la compétence provinciale
puis je le croiserai très très
transparent là-dedans mais moi je vais
lui dire quel genre de données tu as
besoin puis si c'est uniquement une
question d'avoir des données pour lui
qui lui permettrait de nous donner accès
à l'argent qu'on a besoin moi j'ai aucun
problème mais il faut quand même
respecter notre champ de compétence
c'est comme ça que je demande est-ce que
ça bloqué parce que juste pour être
certain de comprendre les données
tout le monde comprend tout ça la
livraison des Services et de compétence
provinciale vous dites on est prêt à
partager certaines données dites nous ce
que vous voulez voilà pourquoi ça s'est
pas rendu là cette semaine à la table
pourquoi ça je pense qu'il manquait une
étape puis c'est pour ça je pense qu'on
va continuer c'est que on n'a pas eu
d'offre rappelez-vous que la demande que
les premiers ministres ont fait je vous
conseille de la Fédération depuis un an
et demi c'est de dire nous le fédéral
vous nous remboursez 22% de nos dépenses
provinciales on veut
35%. moi je vais vous dire la différence
le pôle de Québec ça vaut 6 milliards
par année si on passait de 22% de
remboursement à 35 %. c'est 6 milliards
par année ça non ça me permet
d'augmenter mes soins à domicile ça me
permet de mieux payer mes infirmières ça
me permet une foule de choses alors
c'est un peu pour ça qu'on dit vous
pouvez peut-être dire voici mes demandes
mais dites nous ce que vous nous offrez
c'est comme je vous disais vous voulez
m'acheter ma maison et vous me donnez
pas le prix je vous dis ok vous voulez
vous voulez des choses moi je suis prêt
à vous en donner des données mezzanine
donner combien de plus que le 22 % et
c'est ça qui a pas eu comme offre cette
semaine bon maintenant est-ce que c'est
plus peut-être au ministre au ministre
des Finances de toutes les provinces de
se parler de ça de combiner peut-être la
ce que Monsieur Duclos de bien faire
mais en même temps avec les premiers
ministres je pense que nous on est rendu
donc quand vous entendez
Justin Trudeau dire la semaine dernière
c'est clairement pas seulement une
question d'argent parce qu'il y a des
provinces qui ont les moyens de renvoyer
des chèques à leur contribuables faites
c'est peut-être juste c'est peut-être
autre chose à régler dans le système
vous pensez quoi
mais là je vais pas faire d'erreurs
diplomatiques là mais je pense qu'on
peut marcher puis c'est de la gomme en
même temps je vous dis une chose les
Québécois en terme d'impôts sont les
plus taxés au Canada
ok des Québécois vivent comme des gens
de ce Canada une inflation sans
précédentes ok on a décidé qu'on allait
leur donner des chèques pour les aider à
lutter contre l'inflation on a dit on va
arrêter d'être la province la plus
imposée au Canada mais en même temps on
devrait avoir l'argent qui nous est dû
mais vous l'avez entendu le commentaire
ça fait quoi au négociations c'est un
commentaire je pense que ça aide pas
parce que je pense que québécois
comprenne très bien qu'on peut baisser
les impôts on peut donner des chèques
qui sont non récurrents pour un problème
qui est très spécifique en ce moment
mais que le fédéral doit faire sa part
sur non seulement la portion qui nous
rembourse des dépenses mais le fait que
les dépenses en santé s'accroît à 5-6%
par année parce que la population
vieillit c'est pas juste une question de
coût c'est une question de volume de
plus en plus de personnes âgées puis en
ce moment fédéral remporte pas la
proportion qui devrait au-delà de
l'argumentaire de bon et donne des
chèques là et et Monsieur Duclos et
Monsieur Trudeau disait cette semaine ça
ne peut pas être simplement une question
d'argent il y a on a besoin de brasser
le système parce que comme c'est là ça
fonctionne ça
convient d'ailleurs je suis le premier à
le dire parce que dans le plan de santé
que j'ai déposé un peu plus tôt cette
année j'ai dit que c'est pas juste une
question d'argent ça prend plus d'argent
parce que les volumes sont plus élevés
mais ça prend une meilleure organisation
du travail ça prend des cloisonnement
des professions donc faut pas juste dire
que ça prend de l'argent il faut mieux
travailler dans ce sens-là une meilleure
organisation du travail bon l'autre
élément que Monsieur Duclos amené à la
table cette semaine l'autre demande du
fédéral utilisant celle-là c'était c'est
toute la question de la gestion des
ressources humaines d'une province à
l'autre entre autres la reconnaissance
des de certaines compétences d'une
province à l'autre les gens sont pas
familiers mais un chirurgien par exemple
qui est certifié au Québec qui peut pas
nécessairement pratiquer en Ontario
parce que c'est pas la même
reconnaissance des fois la certification
prend six mois neuf mois un an c'est
vrai que ça peut être un frein à
livraison des services d'une province à
l'autre pourquoi c'est un problème les
différences entre nos ordres
professionnels qui sont de nature
provinciale sont déjà très différents
moi j'ai dit un peu à la blague que si
on essaye de égaliser toutes les
ressources humaines au niveau canadien
on en a pour 10 ans juste essayer de
nous démêler puis de faire un peu le
ménage dans nos offres professionnels au
Québec ça va me prendre quelques années
à faire ça c'est compliqué il y a un
ordre professionnel pour chacun alors je
fais juste dire avant de m'embarquer
avec un autre mammout de ses épaules
j'aime mieux régler celui du Québec puis
c'est pour ça qu'on a dit écoutez vu que
c'est un champ de compétences provincial
c'est pas que c'est pas une bonne idée
ce que vous voulez faire mais c'est
peut-être pas la priorité pour le Québec
en ce moment les provinces demandent
35% afin que Ottawa ça quitte de 35% de
la facture des frais de livraison des
soins de santé 28 milliards à terme ça
coûterait 28 milliards au fédéral est-ce
que vous êtes confiant que ça peut
arriver ce serait un gros bol si le
fédéral qui est ça vous demande ça fait
longtemps qu'on a pas vu pareil pareil
injection de capital fédérale dans le
système de ce qu'il faut faire c'est je
vais vous dire c'est pour ça que j'ai
décidé d'y aller même si on était un peu
hésitant à cause du champ de compétence
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu y aller
pour montrer une porte ouverte à trouver
des solutions c'est tellement important
moi je suis écouté quand on parle du
vieillissement de la population je suis
de ceux qui dans 10 ans bon on va voir
75 ans et c'est là qu'il faut comprendre
qu'on a une augmentation massive de nos
personnes âgées qui maintenant
représentent peut-être 15% de la
population mais presque 50% des coûts
alors ça va augmenter alors si on n'a
pas de l'aide du fédéral
ça marchera pas par ailleurs au début du
mois vous avez annoncé plein pour
soulager les urgences ça va pas ça va
pas très bien encore dans les urgences
au Québec vous aviez l'intention de
libérer 1700 lits où est-ce qu'on en est
là-dessus on a probablement accompli
déjà la moitié de nos objectifs sur les
lits de libérer des lits d'ailleurs on
voit déjà que il y a eu au moins une
stabilité dans les urgences que ça veut
dire c'est que ça a arrêté de se
détériorer parce qu'il y a quelques
gestes qu'on a posé mais c'est sûr que
comme tous les ministres de la santé on
dit avant couvert cette semaine ça va
être un hiver excessivement difficile
parce qu'on lutte contre trois virus il
y a pas juste la covid il y a toute
l'influenceur puis il y a toutes les
maladies respiratoires pour les jeunes
fait qu'on a trois bandes fronts jusqu'à
maintenant grâce au travail qui se fait
dans notre réseau par les gens de la
santé lol la situation s'est stabilisée
mais stabilisé dans un situation je
dirais un set ou un 8 sur 10 on n'est
pas à 10 en terme de dire que ça ça
frappe de partout j'espère qu'on va se
rendre après les dans cette situation ça
serait déjà un accord est-ce que ça vous
inquiète vous venez de le dire en trois
virus la période hivernale toujours plus
raide un peu ça vous inquiète oui ça
m'inquiète puis c'est pour ça que on va
je vais continuer avec le docteur
Boileau à suivre ça de très proche
d'informer les gens c'est quoi
l'étiquette respiratoire qu'on va avoir
je sais que les gens sont années mais on
voit qu'il faut continuer d'aller se
faire vacciner premièrement un mois
avant les fêtes tout le monde devrait
aller le faire dans les prochains jours
pour avoir le temps que votre système
immunitaire se prépare pour être capable
de passer après l'expérience qu'on a sur
notre troisième Noël ça serait le fun de
passer un bon Noël merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur Thibault